hey 42 here something can't be on fire
fire can only be on things welcome to
RIF the US Patent Office insisted on
proof that the Ouija board worked before
granting the patent in 1891 in the
Second World War British troops were
issued with free sheets of toilet paper
a day American soldiers got 22 88% of
women routinely wear shoes that are too
small for their feet 7 u.s. presidents
were born in log cabins
a 1571 law stated that all English men
must wear knitted hats on Sundays there
are more marijuana dispensaries in
Denver Colorado then there are branches
of Starbucks before a raises were
invented bread crumbs were used to rub
out mistakes if you tickle a rat every
day till start laughing as soon as it
sees you a people with higher incomes
generally prefer their loo paper to
unravel over the roll whilst people with
lower incomes prefer it to go under the
opening ceremony of the Beijing Olympics
was the first time a billion people have
watched a sporting event croquet was
dropped as an Olympic sport after 1900
because only one spectator turned up to
watch it's impossible to set fire to a
pool of petrol by throwing the lit
cigarette into it it's also really
really unlikely that shooting the fuel
tank of a vehicle will cause it to
explode it's just not as easy as the
movies make it out to be in 2007
Scotland spend 125 thousand pounds to
develop a new national slogan the
winning entry was welcome to Scotland
the Milky Way gives birth to a new star
every 50 days everyone has at least
50,000 Forte's a day but 95% of them are
the same as the day before thanks for
the view subscribe for more 40
to